number one argues for selection of
components present in the final product
okay so what I mean is you know in the
final product what I'm looking for is
have you picked each media type and put
it in an appropriate place and showed
its unique strengths for instance have
you used text where you wanted to convey
information it was a information dense
kind of thing you wanted to tell all for
instance text is really good at
conveying something impersonally okay so
for instance you know in again internet
story right part of how our one is such
a creepy character is that we don't know
what his motives are for you know two
thirds of the story and it's only in the
final act that we're like oh no this is
totally creepy okay now the way it works
is that we only get texts from our one
that's all we get of his personality
whereas the other character fortress
right we're far more identified with him
because we hear his voice and I'm we're
part of his journey in a much more
personal way so you can see how audio
and text let you could have swapped them
right you could have made our one's
website have the messages playing audio
and you could read fortresses account as
a personal log right he typed out a
journal so with that it would not nearly
have been as effective getting us to
identify with fortress we're done with
grab a sheet I'll identify with him and
feel worried for you like did you do you
know when you when the narrator took
away all of the colored letters and you
just get the yellow message and your
life all over fortress don't go right
that's how I felt right I felt worried
for him and I wouldn't have felt nearly
as worried if I'd heard the voice of I
want have been personally came to him
and personally disconnected from
fortresses we're meant to be he's the
sort of the protagonist right so that is
using the types well but in the project
report I want you to tell me I want you
to explain how you arrived at that
decision right so I want you to explain
what I just said like for instance
suppose you did the project and you did
the prototype and there was a part where
account put text in here but some of the
feedback I got was that I was meant to
feel really connected to this particular
character but I didn't really care for
them at all so I changed that the
selection of components that I used I
select audio to represent my main
character because so do you see how that
rationale is getting part of a project
report it wouldn't make sense for it to
be in the product it's got to be
something that you provide separately so
I want you to do that for every
different component I use the website
for this part because I wanted the user
to interact it in a particular way I
wanted to make them feel like they were
part of the story okay or I didn't use
it I used video in most part because I
didn't want them to feel like they were
part of story I wanted them to feel
helpless because um you know the main
character is doing something and I
wanted the user to experience this that
the other okay so provide an explanation
the next point is about a feasibility
report sort of now a feasibility report
properly is something that you do do you
remember when the systems of elven life
cycle you produce a feasibility report
yeah you do it quite early on right if
you think about all the stages in the
life cycle you have to do early on
because the feasibility report is
something you produce to work out should
I go ahead with this or not and if I do
is it going how do I judge whether it's
going effectively or not okay so
therefore what you're producing here at
the end is not really a feasibility
report because that would have been done
earlier but I still want you to look at
the elements of feasibility report right
so outlander difficulties associated
with technical feasibility all right
examples I wanted to do these camera
angles but my my camera has the zoom
lens so I could do a close-up in Africa
inappropriate way or it didn't have a
wide lens so I couldn't get all of the
scene that I wanted to when I was
indoors okay oh I wanted to conclude an
animation here but I found that the
learning curve which was too steep to
actually incorporate this or I was
designing a game right as some of you
have
and I found that as a technical
feasibility issue for my users they just
they couldn't download it properly there
was some issue with the blocky or the
audio didn't play properly these are
technical feasibility issues right so I
want you out let the difficulties that
we related their operational feasibility
who remembers not operational
feasibility means yeah good okay so
operation will kind of gives you the
clue how what does it fit into the
environment how long does it function in
the environment how does it achieve its
job right so operational feasibility
mainly be to do with when i had my final
product how well did it achieve its
purpose and what challenges did I find
them okay you get a lot of help here I'm
going back to your prototype but the
kind of feedback you got there where did
people your users have challenges with
actually using your product wasn't
confusing I wizard steep learning curve
lastly schedule feasibility okay now
this is what's really important right
you need to think about how you
originally planned out your project
right and if you did your register posts
well the half of your job is done if you
didn't this will be difficult what kinds
of problems did you experience with
actually keeping to your schedule when
you had problems keep into your schedule
why was it and how did you adapt how did
you adjust how did that impact the
project positively or negatively okay so
if you have no recollection of what you
did over the last two months because you
haven't made many register posts or
they're not very descriptive you will
have trouble with this okay but this is
a pretty standard sort of thing to
include a project manager not only do
you want to make a schedule but when it
doesn't get a schedule you've got to
learn some lessons from that okay so
there are all things that you learn
under project management will probably
live into the into the assessment lastly
evaluates project management techniques
you use during development in relation
to number one the system design number
two system production okay now the first
thing to do is what's the key word here
what do you actually be asked to do
evaluate thank you now I've all sort of
often this mode of thinking because I
might be your exams right now right and
I hate it and probably you do too when
you have a question and the key word is
this and you produce you some amazing
stunning detailed response that has to
do with some other key word right and I
have to tell you this is helpful this is
nice but doesn't answer the question
okay so the most common error that
people do here is that they do not
evaluate their project management
techniques they just described them they
just say I did this and this and this
and this and they do describe valid
project management techniques and how
they're related to your actual project
but they don't make a value judgment
they don't say this project management
eating this was really useful I'm so
glad I had a register because it helped
me with this this and this or I did a
Gantt chart and it was totally useless
because of this this or this you know I
didn't keep to it or it was unrealistic
or etc okay so evaluate includes
describe you've got to tell me what you
did but then you've got to assess and
say look these ones are useful these
ones work and this is why okay now
you'll also notice there are two
different parts there that I've
including number one include a system of
design and what techniques did you use
there okay so for instance if you did
storyboarding storyboarding okay excuse
me not all of you did this just walks
out of the 10th class I'm not all of you
did storyboarding and you probably found
that your videos we're not as good those
of you use your story but it would have
had a much clearer idea of how am I
going to fill all that kind of thing and
so that's a project management technique
you used your easiest of design does
that make sense project management
techniques that you use during our
system production even things like for
example early odd we talked about okay
how do you effectively make sure a team
is up is functioning well and
accomplishing be of the
of your team okay even though the dudes
didn't say it I wonder if any of you
recognize that the people you got to
help test your project right they are
part of your team so how did you get
them to effectively function is poverty
well I sort of held your hand I told you
it would be helpful to produce a
performer so that they don't you don't
just say hey what was the project like
they're like okay I guess okay so do you
see your performer your survey was a
project management technique that you
use during production to ensure that you
got useful feedback now was that helpful
to the project was it not helpful to the
project why why not and so on does that
make sense so this is all part of your
evaluation right and there's 12 bucks in
total on your evaluation right so you've
got to know what project management
techniques you used and you've got to
know whether they were useful or not 65
March okay I've had any questions on any
of the stages or elements that are not
being assessed it's all crystal queen
yeah question
yeah yeah okay so a couple of ways
number one I will just look at the
quality of the project right now to give
you a simple example for another and I
think I'm gonna mention this before you
walked in simple example from another
area if you write an essay right and you
write it in under exam conditions okay
it's going to be a disaster right the
logic will be unclear in some places
from paragraph to paragraph to be like
why this why are these paragraphs XD
each other what's the link there is no
link okay there will be spelling errors
your sentences will be probably
constructed so I'll be too long so I'll
be too short and so on now all those
kinds of things are levels of unrefined
bit because you were rushed and this is
the i just got your first draft as it
were right and that's what happens when
we produce first draft everyone does it
even the most skillful people if you
didn't examine their problems okay but
if you submit an essay which you got
like a month to do and they were
spelling errors in it and it isn't clear
how one paragraph goes to another those
kinds of things are unforgivable in a
4-week project right those are things
you should have ironed out by doing your
set earlier and then looking back at the
essay after a week say and change you
into st. oh I thought this was a great
idea before now I realize it sucks it
doesn't make any sense to you change
that right now sometimes we don't do
that because even though we have four
weeks we still leave it to the end and
it's just as if you did it under the
exam conditions and you're under
pressure okay but here i'll be looking
for number one that kind of quality
right there aren't going to be any silly
errors they aren't going to be pages and
links that refer to something which
doesn't exist okay simple things like
that okay but secondly i already have
seen your prototypes I've seen your
prototypes so I know where your projects
came from so I'm going to be comparing
okay how did this scene look before oh
look i can see Steve reshot this part
because the original one was totally
shaky and I actually couldn't see
anything that he was referring to he
wanted to be realistic and from a you
know first person point of view but
after the feedback you got that people
got nauseous after watching the video
they're like okay I'm gonna change that
so that's a level of refinement which is
going to be obvious to me because I saw
what it was and now I see what it is
now does that answer your question yeah
those are the two main things are going
to really keep for